vous êtes un spécialiste michael jackson
et nous on a des supers danseurs ici ok
donc j'aimerais que vous soyez avec moi
pour juger via est le meilleur non non
non le problème c'est qu'on a quand même
un public à garder donc non le meilleur
danseur ça va se jouer entre enora aux
eaux est d'après vous qu'est des
danseurs physiquement je dirais jaunies
français d'ici là il a dit claudy comme
le lait à la fraise
ça n'a rien à voir et bah non c'est
gilbert belge
il est rarissime est un danseur c'est
particulier c'est quoi le style est pas
hambourg est formée aux halles
mais
le manque de tout de rien allez on lance
tout de suite le happening michael
jackson
venez avec moi un rachid on va aller là
bas et on acquiert alors le défi mettre
très simple enora et je vais vous venez
problème capillaire laissé à friser et
on a non mais je sais des fantaisies
capillaires
sauf qu'il tenait je suis juge c'est ça
vous êtes jugé parfait et mes deux
camarades vont êtres vont se confronter
à quelqu'un qui connaît très bien
puisque c'est le faisait officiel de
michael jackson il s'appelle
bonjour alors juste je voudrais savoir
comment vous reprenez votre prénom parce
que j'ai eu peur de l'écorcher mj lille
mj lille c'est d'accord alors m gilles
le principe est simple on va danser sur
billie jean je crois et chacun votre
tour vous allez essayer de reproduire ce
que fait ma shinji mikami vous savez
tout faire les six jeunes aura et on
commence avec angie qu'est ce qu'on fait
on l'espère
hu
non
les zones et
jours
allociné déjà vainement je veux dire la
vérité
c'était super beau mais quel est le
rapport avec michael jackson ne sait pas
faire
bon c'était très bien ce que c'est sexy
quand même vous allez on va là c'est
dans le sexy avec gilles verdez
maintenant geely dont tom même combat
vous pouvez changer les pas si vous
voulez parce que lui il sait tout faire
m
voir
là
auger ça devait être une séance de danse
était essence de rééducation mais
c'était bien vraiment alors le
spécialiste et rachid d'après vous moi
je dirais entre strip tease est
paraplégique il tirait c'était bien
c'était ce que j'ai accompli mon sac
j'ai beaucoup aimé et nora mais je dois
admettre que beaucoup de courage secteur
c'était le coup de pied on peut revoir
stoppé après je vais prendre la décision
le le coup de sifflet
oui
on voit que les mots n'ont pas su voir
mon père c'est gilles gérer les deux les
deux comme julie elle lui ces merveilles
l'aï là il a mis un peu plus de volonté
mais j'aime bien le côté sexy aussi mais
quand même plus proches de michael le
petit coup et non à ces fêtes
mieux